ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen nach
fast 7 Wochen voller Ungewissheit und
voller Angst sind heute Geiseln aus der
Gefangenschaft der Terrororganisation
Hamas freigekommen insgesamt 24 Geiseln
darunter drei deutsche Staatsbürger
werden vom Roten Kreuz nach Ägypten
gebracht im Anschluss sollen sie in
Israel eintreffen hier seht ihr die
Bilder des Konvois am Grenzübergang
Raffa insgesamt sollen innerhalb der
viertägigen Feuerpause mindestens 50
Geiseln die bei dem Terrorangriff der
Hamas am 7 Oktober gefangen genommen
wurden freigelassen
werden ja ihre Freilassung ist Teil
eines Abkommens dass die israelische
Regierung mit der Hamas geschlossen hat
im Gegenzug sollen dreimal so viele
palästinensische Gefangene aus
israelischen Gefängnissen freikommen zum
aktuellen Stand spreche ich gleich mit
unserem ZDF Korrespondenten in telavi ja
wie lief diese Freilassung der Geiseln
heute ab was bedeutet die Feuerpause für
die Menschen im Gazastreifen und welche
Chancen gibt es die verbleibenden
Geiseln durch Verhandlung
freizubekommen das dürfte ungleich
schwieriger werden sagt der
exunterhändler Gerhard Konrad der selber
einmal zwischen der Hamas und Israel
vermittelt hat und mit dem ich gleich
über die heutige Freilassung sprechen
kann außerdem im Stream ein Sprecher von
uniceef der aktuell im Gazastreifen ist
und von der dramatischen humanitären L
dort berichten kann eure Fragen und
Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr wie immer
gerne direkt im Chat mit uns stellen und
teilen oder ihr schickt sie uns per Mail
an
zdfh-li.zdfzdf.de so ist es richtig wir
wollen uns jetzt aber einmal auf den
aktuellen Stand bringen lassen und dazu
schalten wir jetzt zu meinem Kollegen
Michael beverunge der in Tel Aviv ist
guten Abend
Michael guten Abend also 24 Geiseln
sollen freikommen dar auch drei Deutsche
Staatsbürger die Familie von Joni Ascher
was ist über sie bekannt was weißt du zu
denen nicht viel es ist eine Mutter mit
zwei ganz kleinen Kindern noch die eben
auch verschleppt worden ist die haben
beide die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft
und hier auf dem Platz spielt die
Nationalität der einzelnen freigelassen
keine so große Rolle als die ersten
Bilder kamen die Menschen schauen ja auf
die Handys oder auf die Bildschirme von
den Fernsehsendern die hier aufgebaut
haben und als die ersten Bilder kamen
dass die Geisen wirklich auf
israelischenem Boden waren da brandete
Beifall auf und der galt allen Geisen
also die Freude ist hier ganz ungeteilt
auch wenn man die Angehörigen hier
anspricht die sagen es ist egal wer das
ist auch wenn unsere Angehörigen noch
nicht dabei sind sogar hauptsache es
sind die ersten geisern frei nimm uns
bitte einmal mit wie lief die
Freilassung der Geiseln wie lief dieses
Prozedere heute
ab ja das war ein sehr strenges
Protokoll zunächst einmal
wurden die Geiseln noch in Gaza von der
Hamas an Personal vom Roten Kreuz
übergeben dann wurden die quasi vom
Roten Kreuz über die Grenze nach Ägypten
geleitet dort wurden sie von Ägyptern
aber auch wohl von israelischen
geheimdienstleuten
erstmal in Empfang genommen dort wurde
auch überprüft sind das tatsächlich die
Menschen auf der Liste sind auch alle da
fehlt da jemand dann wurden sie in
Bussen über die Grenze gebracht zu einem
Militärstützpunkt im Süden von Israel da
sind sie wohl augenblicklich noch und
von da geh geht es dann weiter Irene
fitzeek fragt uns bei Youtube wie geht
es denn den Geiseln was weißt du über
den Zustand der
Geiseln also es gibt nur eine Info dass
es ihn medizinisch gesehen also physisch
gesehen gut geht mehr weiß man nicht es
gibt natürlich auch noch einige
psychologische Hürden zu überwinden man
muss sich vorstellen diese Geiseln sind
quasi seit 7 Wochen weitgehend isoliert
es ist davon auszugehen dass sie nichts
mitbekommen haben seit jenem 7 Oktober
was mit ihren Verwandten passiert ist
sie wissen nicht wer von meinen Freunden
und Bekannten von meinen Verwandten mein
Vater meine Ehefrau äh sind sie noch am
Leben oder sind sie ermordet worden bei
einigen ist es nicht der Fall und in die
Euphorie der Freilassung wird man Ihnen
jetzt sehr schon beibringen müssen dass
das eben möglicherweise bei einigen
Freunden und Bekannten nicht der Fall
ist Michael du stehst wenn ich das
richtig sehe auf dem Platz vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium wo seit Wochen
immer wieder auch Freunde und Angehörige
der Gefangenen hinkommen
m wie ist die Stimmung dort bzw
wann sie warten da wie gesagt seit
Wochen wann haben Sie die Chance endlich
ihre ihre Verwandten dann auch
wiederzusehen also hier wie gesagt das
ist ein großer Kreis einmal Angehörige
aber eben auch viele Sympathisanten
Unterstützer das ist ja eine ganz große
Bewegung geworden und die Menschen die
heute
Angehörige freigelassene in Empfang
nehmen können die sind heute nicht hier
die sind jetzt schon äh in äh die
Hospitäler wo eventuell die einzelnen
freigelassen hingebracht werden äh sind
sie hingegangen und es gibt auch
Hotelzimmer die extra angemietet worden
sind damit sich die Menschen erstmal
hier äh möglicherweise auch in Tel Aviv
treffen können das heißt die Angehörigen
die heute auf ihre Angehörigen warten
die sind schon informiert die warten
darauf und werden dann wahrscheinlich
noch heute abend äh das erste Mal ihre
Verwandten in die Arme schließen können
Teil dieser Vereinbarung mit der Hamas
ist auch dass dreimal so viele
Palästinenser ich habe es eingangs
gesagt aus israelischen Gefängnissen
freigelassen werden sollen dazu haben
wir auch eine Frage bei Youtube bekommen
und zwar welche Palästinenser wurden
denn freigelassen
bisher das sind 39 an der Zahl 25 Frauen
und 14 meist jugendliche Straftäter die
in Haft saßen bei den Jugendlichen sind
es meistens Vergehen wie Stein oder
Molotov Cocktail werfen bei den Frauen
sind einige bei die tatsächlich auch
größere Terroranschläge verübt haben und
mehrere Personen auch zum Teil schwer
verletzt haben allerdings keine
Mörderinnen dabei darauf hat Israel
bestanden dies werden auch jetzt heute
Abend an das Rote Kreuz hier in Israel
übergeben und dann in ihrer Heimatorte
entlassen das ist zum Teil Ostjerusalem
oder es sind andere Orte im
westjordernland
jetzt soll es bei diesem Austausch der
palästinensischen Gefangenen so hören
wir gerade auch zum Einsatz von
Tränengas gekommen sein hast du dazu
Informationen nein dazu habe ich keine
Information nach den Bildern die ich
gesehen habe wurde im unmittelbaren
Umfeld des Austausches der Geiseln kein
Tränengas eingesetzt ich würde dir gerne
noch eine Frage weitergeben die wir bei
Youtube bekommen haben von Gert Sommer
sind nun alle deutschen frei alle
deutschen Geiseln freigelassen word oder
gibt es noch Menschen mit deutscher
Staatsangehörigkeit die in der Gewalt
heramas
sind nein soweit ich soweit ich weiß
gibt es noch Menschen mit deutscher
Staatsangehörigkeit die in der Gewalt
der Hamas sind oder eventuell auch in
der Gewalt des Islamischen Jihad das
Problem ist ja teilweise auch dass die
Hamas selber gar nicht genau weiß wo
sind die verschiedenen Geiseln
untergebracht da fehlt offenbar auch der
Kontakt und die Abstimmung zum
islamischen hat äh der behauptet 30 bis
40 Geisel in seiner Gewalt zu haben
insgesamt ist ja bis jetzt auch noch
immer nicht ganz hundertprozentig äh
geklärt wie viele Geisen gibt es
tatsächlich wie viele sind
möglicherweise auch schon tot Israel
versucht logischerweise während dieser
Feuerpause möglichst viele Geiseln
freiubekommen die Feuerpause soll
mindestens vier Tage dauern könnte aber
auf maximal 10 Tage verlängert werden
welche Hoffnung gibt es für all die
Geisel die noch in den Händen der Hamas
sind jetzt in den kommenden Tagen
freizukommen also ich denke es gibt gute
Chancen über die 50 Geiseln die jetzt in
den nächsten vier Tagen freigelassen
werden sollen hinaus dass ein ähnliches
Prozedere dann noch mal für 50 Geiseln
stattfinden ich fürfte danach wird es
schwierig äh für wen es ganz schlecht
aussieht das sind die Soldaten die in
der Gewalt der der Hamas sind das sind
Menschen die für die Hamas eine
besonders hohe
Qualität haben als Geisen einen
besonders hohen Wert weil man gegen sie
in der zynischen Währung für Geiseln
besonders viele Gefangene eintauschen
kann ich fürchte aber dass nach einer
gewissen Phase des Waffenstillstands und
des Austausches von Geiseln die
kampfhamlung wieder aufgenommen werden
weil Israel hat ganz klar gesagt wir
werden auch im Süden weiter offensiv
vorgehen äh und je mehr das passiert
desto mehr ist auch das Leben der
verbliebenen Geisel in
Gefahr Michael bwerunge live aus Tel
Aviv vielen dank dir für diese
Einschätzung Einschätzung und Eindrücke
danke dir ja welche Chancen gibt es die
übrigen Geiseln auf diplomatischenem Weg
zu befreien darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit dem exvermittler Gerhard Konrad er
hat
über 30 Jahre für den
Bundesnachrichtendienst gearbeitet und
war selber Vermittler in Verhandlung
zwischen Israel und der Hamas und er ist
mir hoffentlich jetzt zugeschaltet damit
wir das noch einmal weiter vertiefen
können ich höre gerade von den Kollegen
aus der Regie ah da ist er wunderbar
guten Abend Herr Konrad da ist er ja
guten Abend doch noch geschafft doch
noch geschafft wunderbar die herrmas
scheinen sich bisher an die Vereinbarung
zu halten welche Hoffnung machen Ihnen
die Meldung von
heute
ja erstmal kurzfristig die Hoffnung dass
die nächsten vier Tage oder fünf Tage
man wird sehen ob das immer so
drehbuchmäßig funktioniert sie haben ja
schon gesehen der der Teufel der sitzt
ja immer mal wieder im Detail also auch
da die Frage ob die Namen dann zu den
Menschen passen und so weiter das sind
aber meistens Dinge die nur verzögern
die also wahrscheinlich den
gesamtaustausch nicht in Gefahr bringen
werden sollten
danach wird es spannend ob es eben auch
in die zweite Tranche hinein eingeht die
ja von israelischer Seite mit der
Benennung von insgesamt 300
palästinensischen Häftlingen die
freigelassen werden könnten wenn auf der
anderen Seite eben bis zu 100 Geiseln
freigelassen würden ob diese zweite
Tranche tatsächlich nahtlos
angeschlossen werden kann beabsichtigt
scheint es zu sein äh und nehmen wir mal
als Optimisten an das wäre so dann wären
wir jetzt knapp 8 bis 10 Tage älter und
dann stellt sich wirklich die Frage ob
Kampfhandlungen in dem beschriebenen
Ausmaß wieder beginnen oder aber was
durchaus vorstellbar ist eine dritte
Phase in Aussicht gestellt wird von has
denn Hamas dürfte nach meinem meinen
Überlegungen ein erhebliches Interesse
dran haben die weiteren Kampfhandlungen
so lange wie möglich herauszuziehen und
auf die Schwerkraft der Verhältnisse zu
bauen je länger man verhandelt je länger
schauen Sie wenn Sie jetzt dann noch mal
30 weitere Geisel Heras hat ja nun
Vermögen wenn Sie so wollen zynisch
gesagt ne sie haben ja dann immer noch
140 oder 130 sich Geisel äh wenn sie
sagen diesen Prozess wollen wir doch
weiter alle Beteiligten wollen den
weiter aus äh ausführen äh dann wird es
schwierig argumentativ äh wiederum
Militäroperationen
äh in südgasa dann zu allem Überfluss
auch noch loszutreten äh das bleibt als
Drohkulisse auf jeden Fall aber so wie
jetzt die Drohkulisse schon darauf
hingedeutet hat dass Hamas
um seines eigenen Überlebenswillen
Geiseln auf den Markt bringt äh so
möchte ich an nehmen wird das noch mal
ein oder zwei weitere Phasen geben
können bis es zu dem ganz harten herbung
sagte das schon bis es zum harten Kern
kommt das heißt zu den Soldatinnen
Soldaten
aber auch da wird am Ende die Frage sein
konnte sich Hamas
überhaupt in der Zwischenzeit s weit
organisieren rehabilitieren dass sie
dann eine stärkere Position einnehmen
kann gegenüber Israel das ist eine
offene Frage mm das werden wir sehen
Herr Konrad dann lassen Sie uns gleich
über die Geiseln die sie jetzt gerade
angesprochen haben gleich gerne noch mal
weiterprechen vorher erreichen uns hier
noch weiter noch Fragen bei Youtube zu
dem Prozedere was wir jetzt gerade sehen
zu dem Austausch der Geiseln
und zwar fragt Martin Diedrich uns bei
Youtube warum eigentlich der Austausch
im Verhältnis
1:3 ja das Licht also erstens ist das im
historisch gesehen gar kein so
schlechter austauschschlüssel das hat
auch nichts mit der Wertigkeit von
Menschenleben zu tun ich habe die
Polemik verfolgt die ist unsinnig es
geht hier darum äh dass einfach eine
ungleich größere Zahl an
palästinensischen sicherheitshäftlingen
Damen und Kinder und Männer in
israelischer Haft sich befinden und
deswegen ein eins zu ein Schlüssel
selbst von israelischer Seite
als zwar wünschenswert aber nicht
durchsetzbar erscheint denken Sie dran
Gil Chalid wurde damals im Gegenzug zu
1027 Häftlingen freigelassen das war
natürlich eine einmalige Angelegenheit
das werden wir nicht mehr wiedersehen
aber es wird immer ein lobsided Deal
sein wie so schön heißt ein
ungleichgewichtiger das heißt also eine
Geisel und eben ein Z D oder vielleicht
sogar noch mehr das muss man sehen
palästinensische Häftlinge einfach weil
so viele in Haft sind mhm Merlin Feivel
fragt uns bei Youtube wer hat eigentlich
entschieden welche Geiseln freigelassen
werden konnte Israel das Israel das frei
entscheiden oder war das Teil der
Verhandlung
äh soweit ich weiß war das Teil der
Verhandlungen zumindest was die
Kategorien anging das heißt dass man
wohl auch einvernehmlich sagte weil das
wenn Sie wollen sicherheitlich am
einfachsten ist dass man erst einmal
wirklich die ganz strikt humanitären
Fälle nimmt das heißt die armen klein
Kinder äh Frauen kranke Menschen bei den
Frauen wird man wohl differenzieren
müssen also Zivilpersonen nicht
militärische
Personen also keine Soldatinnen die
fallen dann wieder in andere Kategorie
aber das gehört eigentlich zum
gemeinsamen Zeichensatz dass man sagt
Frauen und Kinder wie so schön heißt
Frauen und Kinder zuerst ne so wie wenn
das Schiff untergeht ja äh und deswegen
wird äh ist das glaube ich kein großes
Problem gewesen denn das ist auch am
einfachsten auch für Israel am
einfachsten palästinensische Frauen und
Kinder schrecklich Jugendliche
freizulassen die einfach noch minder
schwere Straftaten in der Regel begangen
haben aus israelischer Sicht mhm welche
Rolle spielen eigentlich oder welche
Position aus Sicht der Herm aber auch
aus Sicht Israels haben eigentlich
Geisel mit einer doppelten
Staatsangehörigkeit in den Verhandlung
die jetzt gelaufen sind und die
Verhandlungen die dann noch folgen
werden tja offiziell äh wohl eher keine
sie werden ja wenn Sie doppelte
Staatsangehörigkeit haben
wird sich Israel in gleicher Weise
verantwortlich fühlen wollen und müssen
für all diejenigen die auch noch ein
zweiten Pass haben äh natürlich ist es
so dass z.B äh die USA insbesondere vor
dem Hintergrund der innenpolitischen
Lage für Joe Biden es überhaupt gar
nicht leisten können zu sagen ja Gott
irgendwann kommen auch die
amerikanischen Israelis frei nicht wenn
Sie wollen ja sondern das sind natürlich
de American citizen
und die müssen relativ frühzeitig äh in
den freilassungskontingenten enthalten
sein das ist einfach schon im hinblck
auf den Wahlkampf
so und das weiß auch Amas mhm und fragt
Johannes bei Youtube macht es aus Sicht
der Hamas eigentlich Sinn so viele
Geiseln freizulassen was würden Sie dazu
sagen ja
gut wenn sie so viele haben können Sie
natürlich schon bisschen Lares zeigen es
kommt dazu dass natürlich
gerade auch die die Babys und die die
Kinder
äh auch natürlich schwache Kranke
Herrschaften die ja auch dabei sind äh
die sind ja letztenendes äh die müssen
sie ja mit größerem Aufwand gesund
halten bei Laune halten wenn Sie wollen
ja sie wollen ja jetzt nicht ähäh mehr
oder minder tote übergeben müssen das
ist ja eher noch mal zusätzlich
rufschädigen wenn es nicht anders geht
werden sie auch das tun ne aber äh der
Ehrgeiz ist schon der hier bella figura
zu machen ne das heißt in dem Fall
sollen aber dann die die lieben Kleinen
nicht W und alle sonstigen Pflege und
sorgebedürftigen zunächst freigelassen
werden man ist sie dann auch los nicht
und sehr sehr zynisch zu sagen ne dann
hat has dafür auch eine Gegenwert
erzielt und man ist eine Sorge weniger
mit einer Sorge weniger behaftet mhm
Herr Konrad dann lassen Sie uns gerne
noch mal auf die jetzt kommenden
Verhandlungen schauen also in den
kommenden Tagen sollen während der
Feuerpause pro Tag ef ich hab es gerade
auch schon im Gespräch mit Michael
bwerunge gesagt zehn weitere Geiseln
freikommen im Gegenzug dann jeweils
dreimal so viele Gefangene aus
israelischen Gefängnissen diese
Feuerpause soll mindestens vier Tage
dauern könnte aber auf 10 Tage
verlängert werden das würde natürlich
auch mehr Tage bedeuten an denen dann
israelische oder Geiseln aus der aus der
Haft der Hamas dann freikommen können
worauf kommt es aus ihrer Sicht jetzt an
dass eben möglichst viele Geiseln
freikommen ja also in der Tat auf die
erfolgreiche Umsetzung dieses Planes es
wird dann noch mal potenziell schwierig
sein wenn das Kontingent wenn Sie wollen
erschöpft ist denken Sie dran die
Bestimmung auch freizulassen der
palästinensische Häftlinge in Israel ist
nichts was gerade so von gestern auf
heute schnell geschieht das ist ein
relativ komplexer Prozess sie müssen
eben geeignete Namenslisten
zusammenstellen geeignete Kategorien das
geht dann auch nach Straffälligkeit
reststrafenverbüßung etc pp das heißt
das dauert ich weiß ob es da schon
vorbereitungs Überlegung gibt ich möchte
es hoffen und annehmen also Jenseits se
300 ne denn sonst haben sie da schon
eine Verzögerung dann könnte in der
grauen Theorie Israel dann noch gar
nicht liefern währendessen Hamas
behaupten könnte ja ja bitteschön wir
könnten aber ohne weiteres jetzt
jenseits der bisherigen Geisel noch mal
äh 20 oder 30 oder 40 anbieten ne aber
sie haben dann die Phase da wird es
spannend es wird der Austausch findet
dann kurzfristig noch nicht statt nach
den 10 Tagen
sie müssen verhandeln und wenn
verhandelt wird kann auch wieder
geschossen werden ne das wäre dann die
Wiederaufnahme die wiederaunahme der
Kampfhandlung bis wieder eine neue
Austauschaktion organisiert worden ist
Herr Konrad wir haben uns ja an dieser
Stelle vor zwei Tagen schon mal zum
gleichen Thema gesprochen und da haben
sie gesagt die Verhandlung die dann
jetzt bevorstehen für die verbleibenden
Geiseln die dürften ungleich schwieriger
werden was glauben Sie denn eine
Prognose wie viele Geiseln werden sich
auf diplomatischem Weg tatsächlich
befreien
lassen ja im da kann man äh erstmal
sagen im Prinzip schon alle ja äh das
ist nicht die Frage es hängt von den
austauschrelationen es hängt vom Preis
von der Bereitschaft beider Seiten ab äh
auf entsprechende Kompromisse einzugehen
und diese Kompromisse werden aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach immer
anspruchsvoller schwieriger werden je
wenn Sie wollen höherrangig äh die
Qualität der Geiseln ist wie ich ih
schon sagte Soldatinnen und Soldaten
werden letztenendes der harte Kern sein
äh gegen und hier wird Hamas sehr hohe
Preise verlangen auch im Hinblick darauf
äh um sich selbst äh wieder in
irgendeiner Weise aus der Schlinge
herauszuziehen der sie sich ja zum jetzt
befindet Hamas steht unter hartem
militärischem Druck äh den sie in
irgendeiner Weise aushalten muss aber
das aushalten muss ja irgendwo zu etwas
führen also entweder Status oder freies
geleid sage ich jetzt mal wenn wenn
Hamas so etwas beabsichtigen wollte und
nicht Zerstörung durch militärische
Schläge ja und wissen wenn Sie wenn Sie
30 oder 40 oder 50 Soldatinnen Soldaten
noch weiter hin dann als Geiseln haben
dann haben sie ja weiterhin ein
Erpressungspotenzial dieses ultimative
Erpressungspotenzial wird Hamas mit nach
meiner
plausibilitätsüberlegung nur gegen eine
entsprechende
Zusicherung für ihre eigene Zukunft
freigeben abgesehen davon dass natürlich
auch eine ganz andere Kategorie von
Häftlingen palästinensischen Häftlingen
dann zur Debatte
steht verstehe ähm Herr Konrad wir haben
bei Youtube kriegen wir natürlich die
ganze Zeit weiter Fragen und eine von
Christ die lautet ist es denn denkbar
dass die israelischen Streitkräfte durch
die Herausgabe der Geiseln jetzt neue
Hinweise auf den Ort bekommen könnten wo
noch mehr Geiseln sich befinden z.B
durch Drohnen oder ähnliches fragt uns
Chris
Entschuldigung geht nicht anders ja
drohenflüge waren ja nun angeblich
während der Übergabe oder sollen
angeblich in der Übergabe der Geiseln
nicht stattfinden ich weiß nicht ob das
implementiert worden
ist natürlich können Sie sagen und die
israelischen Streitkräfte haben das auch
schon mehragt na gut dann machen wir
eben nicht mit drohen sondern mit
anderen Aufklärungsmittel nicht gegen
Satelliten und gegen Überflüge von
Flugzeugen können sie nichts machen
ne also insofern
Herr wenn ich sie kurz unterbreche wir
können auch einmal ganz kurz genau an
dieser Stelle ihn einmal ein Schluck
genau
gönnen ja es hilft nichts son fang ich
an zu weinen nicht Gottes Willen nein
dafür wollen wir nicht verantwortlich
sein aber wenn es für sie in Ordnung ist
dann genau gerne noch mal genau also
welche Hinweise Genen die können diese
jetzt freigelassenen Geiseln den
israelischen Streitkräfte auf den Ort
der noch ver Geisen
geben äh das hängt davon ab wie
geschickt sich Hammers und alle
Beteiligten angestellt haben oder wie
umgeschickt äh das müsste man die
Choreografie die Choreografie dazu die
müsste man sich genau anschauen das kann
ich ihn jetzt so freihändig gar nicht
beantworten aber natürlich gibt es
übergabepunkte nicht also die die Geisel
müssen aus irgendwelchen verstecken
zusammengezogen worden sein und dann
gibt es einen über mindestens einen
Übergabepunkt an denen die Herrschaften
dann wohl an ICRC herausgegeben worden
äh sind und das ICRC hat dann vielleicht
die weitere den weiteren Transport
besorgt das müsste man also ganz genau
jetzt operativ sich anschauen wie das
jetzt heute gelaufen ist um daraus
Schlussfolgerung zu ziehen möglich ist
es und wenn nicht dieses Mal dann die
nächsten Male das ist eben der kritische
Punkt das war auch damals bei
gilatchalid ein ein wichtiger Punkt
immer dass her natürlich größte
Bemühungen unternahmen ja nicht durch
z.B den proof of life oder später eben
auch die Herausgabe operative Strukturen
oder Verfahren äh dem Gegner Preis
zuugeben je mehr sie austauschen je
öfter solche Operationen
stattfinden desto höher steigt natürlich
das Risiko für herß dass die eine oder
andere das eine oder andere Element
erkannt wird wenn Sie das professionell
machen werden sie diese Dinge hinterher
diese Strukturen oder diese
Verfahrensweisen schleunigst wieder
einstellen und sich von den Orten an
denen sie Geisen übergeben haben
zurückziehen
z.B ich habe noch mal eine Frage die wir
bei Youtube bekommen haben an Sie als
sozusagen ja verhandlungsprofi und zwar
fragt uns Johannes was meinen Sie denn
wie weit Israel noch geht bzw wie weit
die Hamas noch geht bei den jetzt
bevorstehenden
Verhandlungen ach wenn ich das das kann
man
pauschal sagen bis bis zum Äußersten
nicht also die Verhandlungen werden
immer härter werden je höher die Preise
werden auch eben und da gehe ich fest
davon aus auch die sogenannten
politische denn außer dem Politikum dass
Hamas hochwertige israelische Geisel in
Händen hat hat Hamas nichts Hamas kann
dann nur noch praktisch die
regionalstaaten bis hin zu westlichen
Staaten natürlich mehr auf seine Seite
indirekt ziehen dadurch dass ich Hamas
ja eben humanitär gesprächsbereit
verhandlungsbereit und austauschbereit
zeigt und mit diesen Mitteln wird Hamas
versuchen wie schon gesagt seine Haut zu
retten ne jedenfalls so gut es geht und
wenn das nicht gewährleistet ist ist die
die Frage sehr offen ob die Geiseln die
soldatinen Soldaten dann in
überschaubarer Zeit auch freigelassen
werden da wird der Druck auf allen
Seiten enorm sein
mhm abschließend Herr Konrad gerne noch
eine Frage von Madlen die ich nicht
unter den Tisch fallen lassen möchte und
zwar was weiß man denn oh Entschuldigung
jetzt bin ich hier genau ne jetzt war
ich kurz in der Zeile verrutscht und
zwar fragt uns matl was weiß man denn
über den Zustand der restlichen Geiseln
insbesondere den Zustand der
Kinder was wissen sie dazu bzw aus ihrer
Erfahrung was was können sie da mutmaßen
ja also also genau wissen tun wir
solange nicht solange nicht das IKRK
ICRC Rote Kreuz
Zugang zu den geistel bekommt das hat
sich ja wohl zerschlagen das hat glaube
ich Netanyahu zu Beginn der
Kabinettssitzung in Aussicht gestellt
aber davon höre ich nichts mehr dass es
also jetzt Gefangenen Besuche gäbe bei
Hamas das würde Hamas allein schon aus
operativ sicherheitlichen Gründen
ablehnen das war in meiner Zeit auch
schon so und heute ist der Druck ja noch
viel größer auf Hamas das hätte mich
also sehr gewundert wenn gleiches toll
gewesen wäre ist aber wahrscheinlich
nicht so das heißt wir wissen nichts wir
werden jetzt sehen äh wie es den
äh befreiten Geiseln den freigegebenen
Geisen gegangen ist äh da werden äh die
Israelis bestimmt auch und das Rote
Kreuz auch entsprechend Fragen stellen
äh nach einer gewisen Erholungszeit sie
werden sehen wie die nächsten zwei D
vier Tranchen äh der freigelassenen äh
Geiseln ähm sich fühlen welchen
Gesundheitszustand haben und dann können
sie da nach dem Prinzip Hoffnung äh eine
Konjektur vornehmen sagen ja wenn es
denen so geht wird's den meisten anderen
hoffentlich auch halbwegs ordentlich
gegangen sein es ist recht
unwahrscheinlich wiederum es ist recht
unwahrscheinlich dass man leichtfertig
oder gar mit schlechter Absicht mit den
Geiseln umgegangen wäre das ist
jedenfalls die bisherige Rationalität
von der Maß gewesen ja im Umgang
allerdings muss man dazu sagen einer mit
einer Geisel ne eben gilat schalid
deswegen muss man da vorsichtig sein aus
dem alten Fall einfach die Lehren für
die neuen Fälle so zu ziehen sag ja das
wird bestimmt so sein aber wir wissen
bisher noch nicht vom Gegenteil denkt
sie auch an die beiden alten Damen die
recht früh freigelassen worden waren die
sagten uns ist es nach der eigentlichen
Entführung die abscheulich war auch
physisch sehr abscheul ich war
danach ist es uns halt halbwegs
ordentlich gegangen da dürfen wir gar
nicht meckern und klagen
wenn das so zutrifft
dann können wir weiterhin bis zum Beweis
des Gegenteils
vorsichtig optimistisch
sein Herr Konrad dann danke ich Ihnen
für heute Abend für ihre Einschätzung
und für ihre Zeit und bis zum nächsten
mal vielen
Dank jo gerne geschehen alles Gute DANKE
DANKE SCHÖN wir wollen jetzt noch mal
auf die ja dramatische Lage die
dramatische humanitäre Lage im
Gazastreifen schauen die spitzt sich
immer weiter zu und darunter leiden vor
allem die schwächsten unter ihnen viele
Kinder auf der Suche nach Schutz vor den
Kämpfen sind viele mit ihren Familien in
den Süden des gaserstreifens geflohen
Anne roseehck berichtet von
dort eng an eng wohnen die Menschen die
nach hanjunis geflüchtet sind eine von
ihnen ist
R zwei Häuser im ersten Haus sind die
Fenster kaputt gegangen als sie die
Moschee neben uns bombardiert haben an
den Glasscherben haben wir uns verletzt
und im zweiten Haus gab es weder Wasser
noch Strom dann kamen wir
hierhin hier ist alles anders eine
Abwechslung gibt es nur wenn Sie mit
anderen Kindern spielen
kann wir spielen zusammen um den Krieg
zu
vergessen alle kommen gerne zu den
Angeboten die Erwachsene sowie Fatima
für Sie anbieten damit Sie besser mit
ihrer Situation
klarkommen die Kinder an diesem Ort
brauchen in erster Linie psychologische
Betreuung wir spielen mit ihnen singen
und erzählen Geschichten dabei machen
sie gerne mit und kommen immer
wieder spielen gegen die Angst für die
Kinder in Gaza das Beste was Sie gerade
für sich selbst tun
können ja und über die Situation der
Kinder und der restlichen
Zivilbevölkerung im gaserastreifen habe
ich mit James elder von uniceef
gesprochen er ist derzeit im Süden des
gaserstreifens das Gespräch mussten wir
aus technischen Gründen vor ungefähr
zweieinhalb Stunden aufzeichnen und ich
habe ihn gefragt sie haben in den
vergangenen Tagen gewarnt die
Wiederherstellung der Wasser und
abwasseraubereitung entscheidet darüber
ob tausende Kinder leben oder sterben ja
wie schlimm ist die Lage
aktuell das ist wirklich absolut schlimm
also ich habe heute lang Zeit in den
Lagern zugebracht die Menschen sind da
eng aneinander und das Abwassersystem
funktioniert nicht die Kinder sind
draußen es ist kalt sie haben keinen
Zugang zu der Wärme die sie brauchen und
viele von diesen Familien im Krankenhaus
mit Kindern die Durchfall hatten die
haben wasserübertragene Krankheiten ich
habe mit einem Vater gesprochen der hat
ein Z Jahre altes Kind 9 Monate altes
Kind und er sagt sagte mir ich möchte
nur eines machen wenn dieser Krieg
vorbei ist ich möchte nur noch weinen
die Menschen versuchen sich irgendwie
durchzuschlagen aber Hunderte von
Menschen versuchen eine Toilette zu
erreichen oder eine Dusche also die
sanitäre Situation ist absolut
katastrophal für die Menschen hier sie
sagen die sanitäre Situation ist
katastrophal woran fehlt es noch was
fehlt den Menschen im gaserstreifen
aktuell am
meisten
Wasser Wasser und zwar trinkbares
Wasser der
Durchschnittsdeutsche verwendet
wahrscheinlich ungefähr 150 oder 200
Liter Wasser pro Tag in
Gaza bevor das alles anfing hat man hier
100 Liter pro Tag pro Person gehabt das
ist jetzt bei dre oder 4 lit Wasser pro
Person und das ist natürlich ein Rezept
für den Ausbruch von und noch mehr
Toten als durch die Bombardements also
sauberes Wasser ist der absolute Fokus
im Moment und dann natürlich Medizin
Zelte und solche Dinge aber es ist vor
allen Dingen Wasser Wasser und Wasser
das brauchen wir und das steht zwischen
dem Leben und dem Tod der Kinder hier in
diesem humanitären
Horror die Feuerpause die jetzt seit dem
Morgen gilt die soll mindestens vier
Tage halten welche Hoffnung haben sie
dass sich die Situation für die Menschen
im Gasastreifen in dieser Zeit
verbessert ja wir wissen natürlich wie
viel
hilfsliieferungen notwendig sind und ein
bisschen Hilfe kommt ja auch schon aber
es war überhaupt nicht genug und das
haben wir von Anfang an gesagt das ist
ja ein ganz kleines Zeitfenster um die
Hilfslieferungen zu erhören milonen von
Litern Wasser an die Menschen zu
bekommen oder sanitäre Dinge für die
jungen Mädchen hier
aber diese
Feuerpause die muss zu einem Frieden
führen wir können nicht
ernsthaft nach vier Tagen einer
humanitären Feuerpause wieder
zurückgehen wo dann 100 Kinder pro Tag
getötet werden das darf nicht sein so
jetzt im Moment ist es ganz wichtig dass
Organisationen wie unizef den Menschen
Hilfe geben die dringend dieser Hilfe
bedürfen und das muss zu einem
langanhaltenden Frieden führen und das
ist ganz wichtig für die Kinder in
Palästina und auch in
Israel sie haben es jetzt schon gesagt
am besten für die Menschen für die
Situation der Menschen vor Ort ist die
ist das Ende der Kämpfe israel hat jetzt
aber schon angekündigt die Kämpfe nach
der Feuerpause
fortzusetzen was muss jetzt ganz konkret
neben einer Verbesserung der der
sanitären Situation einer Versorgung mit
Wasser was muss jetzt schnellst möglich
passieren um das Leben der Menschen vor
Ort zu
verbessern also drei Dinge vor allen
Dingen also die Kanonen müssen aufhören
zu schießen wenn die Kämpfer aufhören
wird alles viel einfacher werden in
meinen 20 Jahren bei un habe ich so
viele Kinder mit Kriegsverletzung
gesehen in so kurzer Zeit sehen wir das
heute hier und die ganze Infrastruktur
ist zerstörte muss wieder zusamm
gebracht werden in diesem
unfun dieser Situation brauchen wir
Generatoren wir brauchen mechanische
Geräte das wäre ganz wichtig wir
versuchen Dinge wieder
und wir brauchen Kraftstoff das ist ganz
ganz wichtig und wir brauchen hunderte
Millionen von Litern Wasser und wir
brauchen Kraftstoffe das ist etwas
worauf sich UNICEF konzentriert wir
wissen was gebraucht wird wir müssen
jetzt die Lieferungen nach Gaser bringen
und wir hoffen dass diese humanitäre
Feuerpause noch länger dauert für die
Menschen
hier Herr sie haben in den vergangenen
Tagen unter anderem auch
sicherheitszusagen für Helfer im
gaserastreifen gefordert beschreiben Sie
uns bitte einmal ganz kurz was macht
ihre Arbeit im gaserastreifen derzeit so
schwierig und so
gefährlich ich denk was es so schwierig
macht für viele Kinder hier das ist ja
das gleiche es gibt keinen sicheren Ort
im Gazastreifen das haben wir immer
wieder gehört das stimmt auch ob letzte
Nacht hört man die Granaten oder vor
zwei Nächten da war so dass Kollegen
hier in diesem Raum sich unter den
Tischen verstecken müsen mussten weil
Granaten in der Nähe
explodierten meine Kollegen bei der
UNRWA die haben das größte Mandat hier
in MA sind mehr als 100 Kollegen getötet
worden mehr als 100 viele sind auch
getötet worden als sie zu Hause waren
mit ihren Kindern und deren Kinder sind
auch getötet worden das ist also als
Hilfe als als hilfegeber sehr sehr
gefährlich hier aber die Menschen
arbeiten weiter in den Krankenhäuser in
den Schulen wo jetzt viele flüchtinge
hingehen sie versuchen die Helfer
versuchen zu tun was sie können um Hilfe
an die Familien und ihre Kinder zu
bringen Herr elder abschließend noch
einmal sie haben natürlich gesagt das
Beste für die Menschen vor Ort wäre ein
Ende der Kämpfe die ist das Ende dieser
Kämpfe ist wenn die Feuerpause vorbei
ist aber jetzt erstmal nicht in Sicht
welche tive sehen Sie dann für die
Menschen im
Gasastreifen ich glaub heute ist ein
guter Anfang in diesem relativen Horror
der letzten se Wochen heute sehen wir
auch dass israelische Kinder
freigelassen wurden und ist f schon von
Anfang an seit dem 7
Oktober das verlangt ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen wie schlimm das für die
Eltern gewesen sein muss
wir fangen jetzt an dass die
israelischen Kinder wieder sicher sind
und sicher nach Israel kommen aber
gleichzeitig müssen uns auch um die
palästinensischen Kinder hier kümmern
und das bedeutet sicheres Wasser mehr
Nahrung medizinische Versorgung das ist
wichtig viele Krankenhäuser
funktionieren einfach nicht mehr und wir
müssen zivile Bereiche beschützen und
das ist noch nicht
passiert ich habe heute dicht besiedelte
Gebiete gesehen die angegriffen wurden
die Zivilisten müssten sicher sein und
im Moment ist das einfach nicht der Fall
und war nicht der Fall wähend der
letzten sech Wochen James elder Sprecher
von uniceef vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
und für die Antworten heute danke
schön bitte
schön ja soweit unser ZDF heute live zur
aktuellen Lage im gazaastreifen und zu
den Geiseln die heute freigelassen
wurden in den kommenden Tagen sollen
weitere Geiseln im Austausch gegen
palästinensische Gefangene aus
israelischen Geis aus israelischen
Gefängnissen freikommen aktuelle Infos
dazu findet ihr wie immer in der ZDF
heute App danke euch für heute fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten
Mal